من القاهره للامم الحديث عن مستجدات قضيه
علي عبد الفتاح
التامر عز الدين اهلا بك تامر يعني منذ
قليل تحدثنا عن بدء ثلاثه صحفيات مصريات
اضرابا عن الطعام في مقر النقاب نقابه
الصحفيين وسط القاهره يطالبون بالافراج عن
علاء عبد الفتاح الذي بدا اضراب عن الشربه
ايضا بعد الطعام وتضامن ايضا مع السجناء
السياسيين هل من اي ردود فعل لهذا الاضراب
يعني حكى الان لا توجد
صحفيات اعلنا اليوم عن البدء في الاضراب
عن طعام ايمان عوف ومنى سليم ورش عزب قال
ان هم سيبداون ادراك عن الطعام بتاريخ
اليوم والاعتصام داخل مقر النقابه الصحفي
للمطالبه بالافراج على المعتقلين الراي
والتعبير في مصر وتضامن مع ادراك علاء عبد
الفتاح هو كانت هناك دعوات منذ
الامس لاضراب تضامني لمده 24 ساعه اطلقها
عدد من الوسطاء والصحفيه على صفحتهم
الشخصيه على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
للتضامن مع علاء عبد الفتاح الحلبي همم
اسرته عدد من منظمات الحقوقيه للحصول على
عفو رئاسي عنه حتى رئيس الوزراء البريطاني
الذي يحضر قمه في شرم الشيخ قال انه اعلن
صراحه انه سيتم تطرقه الى قضيه علاء عبد
الفتاح هل اعتبار انه يحمل ايضا الجنسيه
البريطانيه صح اه تحددوا عدد من المطالب
حتى همم يوقفوا هذا همم الاضراب والاعتصاب
همم اولها اخلاء سبيل همم علاء عبد الفتاح
فورا اطلاق سراح الصحفيين المعتقلين سواء
كانوا من اعضاء نقابه الصحفيين او غير
نقابيين وقت ملاحظه ملاحقه الصحفيين في
قضايا النشر فتح المجال العام في مصر
وقيام نقابه الصحفيين بدورها ووقف
الملاحقه الامنيه المستمره لاصحاب الراي
وطرح حلول جبريه لقضيه السجناء السياسيين
واطلاق صلاح كل من لم يتورط في عمل العنصر
ولكن حتى الان لا توجد ردود فعل ذلك اذا
هذه همم هذا الاعلان عن الاعتصام في
الرقابه الصحفيين او الادراك كما لم يرد
رد فعل رسمي مصري بخصوص علاء عبد الفتاح
حتى الان هناك عدد من قوائم العفو الرئاسي
التي تم همم التصديق عليها من قبل رئيس
الجمهوريه في الفتره الماضيه واخيه سبيل
عشرات في الفتره الماضيه ولكن منظمه العفو
الدوليه تقول ان الاعداد التي تم القبض
عليها خلال الايام الماضيه تفوق عدد من كم
العفو عنهم فيما لم يتم هناك اي تعليق من
السلطات المصريه على هذا الامر هناك لجنه
عفو تم اعاده تشكيلها تقوم بتقديم الاسماء
اسم علاء عبد الفتاح واخرين كانوا من ضمن
الاسماء الذي قدمت في همم جميع المرات
ولكن حتى الان لم يتحصل عبد الفتاح او
الاسماء اخرى من المحامي محمد الباقر وعبد
المنعم ابو الفتوح واخرين لم يتم صدور
قرار بالعفو عنهم حتى الان البعض يعول على
ان اضراب علاء علاء
المياه بعد فتره طويله من الادراك التدريج
عن الطعام قد تشكل نوع من الضغط مع تدخل
الحكومه بريطانيه حتى يتم اخلاقه
في القاهره